it's the perfect time of year to hunker
down inside for a movie night or
dedicate a weekend to binge watching a
new series there's no need to head out
to the theater here are a few Netflix
originals you've probably missed so far
proving that 2019 is the year Netflix
goes totally international justice tells
the story of Farah a young woman from
the United Arab Emirates who studied law
in the United States and returns to her
home city of Abu Dhabi in order to
practice her father is one of the top
attorneys in the UAE and he's pleased to
see Farah follow in his footsteps but
there's a catch bara wants to work for
herself and open her own practice but
her father wants her to work at his firm
in order to prove herself
Farah begins taking on intriguing pro
bono cases which are based on real cases
that have gone through Abu Dhabi's
justice system with true to life
characters who are caught between
tradition and modernity justice gives
viewers a peek into family life in the
UAE
and the series is educational as it is
entertaining Fatima al Tully's portrayal
of Farah is sympathetic and relatable
and she makes the characters ambitious
nature shined through in every scene
when a series kicks off with a theme
song written by the legendary Leonard
Cohen expectations are going behind and
from the intro sequence to the end
credits Black Earth rising does not
disappoint protagonist Kate Ashby is
rescued from the aftermath of the
Rwandan genocide as a child by her
adoptive mother Eve who works as a
successful international human rights
lawyer kate eventually grows to work up
side by side with eve as a legal
investigator when eve prosecutes a
militia leader who stood up against
genocide in the Democratic Republic of
Congo but now finds himself accused of
crimes against humanity Kate and Eve
have to grapple with the difficult
questions surrounding good evil and the
complexity of morality and where they
stand in their relationship with each
other
I don't remember my family oh my country
nothing I don't know my name Black Earth
rising comes with some familiar star
power in the form of John Goodman as
Kate's employer but it's not the kind of
series you can zone out on each episode
pushes viewers to think critically and
refuses to spoon-feed
answers to the issues it presents in the
world of black earth rising nothing is
really black or white and everything
exists in shades of gray
the Icelandic film and breathe normally
premiered at the Sundance Film Festival
in January 2018 to overwhelmingly
positive critical reception now it's
available for Netflix audiences
everywhere Lara is a struggling single
mother living near Reykjavik who forms
an unlikely bond with odd ja a refugees
seeking asylum who was about to be
deported Lara is nothing if not stubborn
and she seems like the last person to
accept help from a stranger on the other
hand
Asha has almost nothing to give but
somehow she offers Laura what little
support she can to her and Laura allows
herself to be vulnerable and let Asia
into her world and breathe normally
touches on several topics that dominate
today's headlines from Lara's attempts
to disguise poverty as an adventure for
her son two scenes in the refugee center
where Asha lives in limbo do you know
how long I have to stay here this is not
the site of Iceland that you see in
tourism ad campaigns the cold rocky
landscape is the backdrop for a nuanced
look at this seemingly utopian nation
combine the exciting fight scenes of a
martial arts film with the tension of a
drama series
throw in some supernatural elements and
you've got wu assassins kai shen a chef
working in San Francisco's Chinatown
learns his true identity he's actually
the last of the wu assassins a line of
warriors tasked with using their powers
to kill the wu warlords the Warlord's
also possess magical abilities connected
to fire earth water wood and metal San
Francisco is now under threat from the
Warlord's and despite Kai's protests
that he's just a chef he has no choice
but to step up embrace his new role and
fight against them the high points of wu
assassins are definitely too tightly
choreographed fight scenes this is star
eco you wises first TV series but his
previous work has a fight an action
choreographer on films like the raid
definitely prepared him for this role
the show has received some criticism for
its lackluster writing and pacing issues
and a few rough special
that's but if it's renewed for a second
season the cast and crew has already
created an imaginative world of
interesting characters on which to build
a strong sophomore effort the follow-up
to met achieve masters of Florence
Medici the Magnificent takes place 20
years after the events of the first
season and introduces several new cast
members including Sean Bean of Game of
Thrones Fame and Alessandra master
naughty who you might have seen on
Netflix his own master of none set in
15th century Florence Medici the
Magnificent continues to focus on the
lives of Florence's most influential
family the Medici after Piero de Medici
is killed his son Lorenzo has to take
back control of their family-run bank
nicknamed Lorenzo the Magnificent he
decides to change the way his family
does business which stirs up trouble
with Florence's other powerful banking
clans the Pazzi now Jacobo patsy is dead
set on bringing Lorenzo down a change to
Rome may bring change to Florence and
with Piero recording loans there may be
better ways of destroying the Medici
than with a blade fans will be happy to
see this series return with fresh faces
and an engaging new plot Medici the
Magnificent was certainly written for
maximum drama over historical accuracy
but who wouldn't want to dive into
centuries-old conspiracy theories about
Florence high society for a few hours
sony has already been labelled the
biggest hindi Netflix originals so far
which is certainly an impressive
accolade headstrong protagonist Sony is
a policewoman in Delhi a city where the
justice system rarely gives women the
benefit of the doubt alongside her
superintendence kalpana the two have
taken it upon themselves to investigate
violent crimes against women the women
balance each other out
Sony is bold and hot-headed while
kalpana always manages to remain calm
but when sony is transferred out of
their department after facing
allegations of misconduct their
partnership takes a hit rather than
veering into buddy-cop tropes sony is an
unapologetically feminist film with a
thoughtful and honest depiction of the
issues that women in India face between
their very different roles at work and
at home
Sony and Kalpana seem to live double
lives a predicament that will be
relatable to audiences around the world
the Spanish horror film Animas is
getting mixed reviews but if you happen
to be staying in on a dark and stormy
night
it's the perfect movie to fit the mood
written and directed by Laura Albea the
plot of animus is centered around
Abraham and Alex friends who struggle to
maintain their close bond when abraham
begins dating his new girlfriend unchi
somehow watches arrival into Abraham's
life kicks off a series of increasingly
strange and frightening events from the
death of Abraham's abusive father to
Alex's unsettling and unexplainable
visions NMS falls squarely into the
category of atmospheric or the
flickering lighting combined with the
appropriately garish color palette makes
every scene feel a little bit like a bad
trip
there's a pervasive sense of isolation
that separates Alex and Abraham from the
rest of the world and it always seems
like they're trapped with no one coming
to save them from themselves a series
that starts off by introducing a
recently widowed protagonist who lost
her husband in a car accident
sounds like it would lean heavier on
tragedy than comedy but debt to me
consistently dabbles in black humour in
its depiction of grief just can't
imagine what you're going through
well it's like if Jeff got hit by a car
and died suddenly and violently like
that christina applegate stars is Jim a
young widow mourning the loss of her
husband who meets Judy played by Linda
Cardellini at a support group sparking
an unlikely friendship but Judy's
unwavering support and carefree attitude
might not be the saving grace that Jen
was hoping for when Jen invites Judy to
live in her guest house
she quickly finds out that Judy tends to
leave trouble in her wake and her past
is definitely catching up to her debt to
me could have gone for mainstream drama
but the raw realistic portrayal of
female friendship and appropriately dark
quips and one-liners are what make it so
binge worthy it dodges tired tropes at
every turn and keeps you hooked right
through the finale with acclaimed
filmmaker Ava Duvernay serving as the
co-creator writer and director of women
ACS it's clear that the series is a must
watch and there's a good chance that it
will turn your worldview on its head
before the credits roll Davern a is
known for her films exploring racism in
the history of civil rights in the
United States like
elma and xiii and her skill at clearly
illustrating how these issues still
affect our society today she continues
down that path with this series which is
based on a 1989 case often refer to as
the Central Park five when a female
jogger was attacked while out running
through Central Park five young men
between the ages of 14 and 16 for black
and one Hispanic were convicted of the
crime despite a lack of hard evidence
all of them served prison time but in
2002 the convictions were finally
overturned when DNA evidence confirmed
the validity of another man's confession
the Vernay actually refused to use the
Central Park five moniker in the series
stating she wanted the men to be seen as
individuals this dramatic expose of the
criminal justice system is impossible to
look away from Indy language films and
series are having a moment on Netflix
proving that there's more to India's
film industry than Bollywood musicals
the series typewriter is set in Goa a
region of India known by travellers for
its popular beaches and quaint fishing
villages but when three aspiring young
Ghost Hunters decide to explore a
supposedly haunted villa they have to
confront the dark forces at work in
their neighborhood when a new family
moves into the villa the terrifying
legends whispered about the house come
to life curiously enough the haunting
itself seems to be connected to an old
typewriter and trying to remove it from
the house proves to be a dangerous
mistake the young protagonists setting
out to solve a supernatural mystery
welcomes comparisons to stranger things
but typewriter isn't just filler to hold
you over until Netflix takes you back to
Hawkins the series stands on its own and
it's legitimately frightening the
overarching plot isn't particularly
unique in the horror genre done deniable
avenge worthy with only five episodes
you might be tempted to watch it all in
one night be warned you'll probably want
to sleep with the lights on they say
that a dog is a man's best friend and
the Spanish comedic drama 17 proves that
there's no bond like the one between a
boy and his pup Hector a troubled teen
who couldn't keep himself from getting
dragged in front of a judge has spent
the past two years living in a youth
detention center and he's dedicated most
of that time to trying to figure out how
to
after training a therapy dog sheep as
part of the program that the local
shelter and finally begins feeling
content but when sheep is adopted by a
new owner actor decides he's had enough
actor breaks out of the center and gets
in touch with his brother and
grandmother and listing their help to
track down sheep sure they'll have to
commit a few crimes and misdemeanors
along the way which is never bothered
Hector in the past now though there is
only one catch
he has two days before he turns 18 and
could be tried as an adult
in 1988 police officer thomas la cartes
obsession with tracking down an elusive
serial killer takes hold several victims
in Philadelphia have bled to death from
similar wounds and Lockhart becomes
convinced that if he can just crack this
difficult case they'll finally get to
become a detective but the mysterious
suspect continues to thwart him for
years on end leaving him with nothing
but inexplicable Clues and dead ends
nine years later Lockhart has moved
forward in his career and become a
detective a copycat killer strikes and
as Lockhart tries to connect the dots he
realizes that the details just aren't
adding up this is not just a serial
killer at work
there's something bigger at play here
when Lockhart encounters his prime
suspect from 1988 and sees that she
hasn't aged a day he dedicates his life
to figuring out her identity her motives
and whether or not she's from an
entirely different time in place or I
tell me the more you keep coming after
me and I've seen how that turns out
in the shadow of the moon is a
refreshing take on the typical police
procedural and the supernatural elements
keep it from feeling like a carbon copy
of similar narratives in the genre the
surprising conclusion explores complex
moral issues and examines the true
meaning of justice if you're a huge
Marvel fan and you just can't get enough
of seeing superhero stories come to life
on screen the charming and occasionally
nail-biting series raising Dione might
be right up your alley most popular
superhero films follow well-known
comic-book characters in their adult
years but what were these
larger-than-life figures like as
children
okay not set anything on fire in raising
D on a widowed single mother Nicole was
taking care of her son Dion on her own
after the death of her husband and as if
the overwhelming responsibilities of
being a single mother weren't enough
beyond begins exhibiting magical
abilities he doesn't quite understand it
he's a superhero in the making
unfortunately it's not all fun and games
for Dion powerful forces are out to
exploit him for their own ambitions and
now Nicole must enlist help to protect
it plus she needs to figure out how he
developed his powers in the first place
and what his future might hold beets is
the latest feature offering from
director Chris Robinson we made his
feature film debut with the drama
ATL in 2005 Robinson is best known for
his work directing music videos for
artists like Alicia Keys Eminem and
Nicki Minaj and his knowledge of the
business clearly informs the plot of
beets bonus the soundtrack is packed
with songs by up-and-coming hip-hop
artists August is an introverted
teenager who is reeling after the loss
of his sister while he shuts himself
away in his room and shirks his
responsibilities he throws himself into
his only creative outlet
music when school security guard romelo
drops by his house to speak to August's
mother about his absence he overhears
the beats August has been working on and
is immediately intrigued by a surprising
Talent Rowe has a surprise of his own up
his sleeve he's also a music manager and
now he wants to take August under his
wing
but August's heavy grief and
insecurities threatened to weigh him
down as he tries to rise to the occasion
you can't
I'm not good
everywhere I go I see it
the story of a young underdog trying to
break into a tough industry with
guidance from an unexpected mentor isn't
a particularly original concept in
itself but the characters and beads are
the real highlight August is sensitive
and conflicted eager to strive for more
yet fragile in the wake of his sister's
death supporting characters like
August's protective mother Carla played
by oranges the new blacks whose o dooba
round out a solid cast from the very
first episode of the chosen one you know
that the outlook isn't promising for the
main characters after all messing with
villagers who would rather be left alone
has been the downfall of protagonists
throughout film history a group of
doctors is sent deep into the Brazilian
wetlands to vaccinate the residents of
an isolated village against the Zika
virus but despite the good intentions of
Lucia DeMaio and Enzo it's clear that
they're not going to be welcomed with
open arms
the villagers aren't just hostile
because they don't want to be bothered
by outsiders they outright refuse to be
vaccinated insisting that polluting
their bodies with modern medicine caused
them to lose the protection of the
chosen one their local religious figure
the doctors must grapple with the
burning questions of science and faith
to dig up the secrets at the heart of
this village and determine if something
beyond their rational understanding is
really a play the acting in the chosen
one might feel a bit more reminisce into
the soap opera than prestige TV but that
doesn't detract much from the
entertainment value and with only six
addictive episodes in its first season
easy to race through this series in a
few hours the last Czar's is that kind
of rare show that's both entertaining
and educational this visually appealing
historical drama series switches between
fictional reenactments and documentary
style commentary to provide further
context which makes for an interesting
format reminiscent of a History Channel
program it might not resonate with those
who would prefer to simply lose
themselves in the story but you'll
appreciate the extra background info if
you're the type who often find yourself
googling questions while watching period
pieces if your knowledge of Russian
history starts and ends with the
animated film Anastasia the last czars
might help fill in a few of gaps the
series follows the life of tsar nicholas
ii his resistance to political change
the ensuing revolution and the
all of the Romanov dynasty if you can
let a few historical inaccuracies in the
background slide the royal scandals
intricate costumes and intriguing
portrayals of the Romanov family will
more than make up for it the names may
sound familiar but the series brings
these historical figures to life in a
way that explores their humanity check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]